this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month and 30 days for free if you sign
up at curiosity stream calm /ba graphics
use the code buyer graphics more on them
in a bit on November the 26th 1922
Egyptologist Howard Carter entered the
tomb he'd discovered a few weeks prior
after decades of fruitless searching he
found something more amazing than he
could have ever hoped for when asked if
he saw anything inside he simply replied
yes wonderful things Carter had located
the tomb of a pharaoh from the 18th
dynasty who ruled over ancient Egypt
during the 14th century BC more
importantly though it was a tomb that
had been mostly undisturbed for over
3,000 years that Pharaoh was Tutankhamun
who ascended to the throne as a young
boy and who died when he reached out
altered his life was short and lacked
accomplishments but that did not matter
for Tutankhamun death was only just the
beginning he achieved far more glory and
fame and death than he could ever have
dreamed of while he ruled over the land
of the Nile
this young king and his tomb rich with
artifacts helped modern society
understand ancient Egypt far better than
anyone else and in the process turns
King Tut into the most famous Pharaoh in
history
okay let's start off with the name we
all know him as Tutankhamun but things
were not really that simple
in fact according to the raw protocol of
ancient Egypt the full title of the
pharaohs contained five names first was
their Horus name the oldest name which
dated all the way back into prehistory
in Tut's case this was cognate to Thomas
suit
then came the Nebuta name or the two
ladies referring to the goddesses
Nekhbet and watchit Fatah this was never
a poo Sagar a Tawi then there was the
golden horrors name which for taught was
wet chess Caju sale tap net guru lastly
there was a throne a more personal name
they were the ones that pharaohs were
typically referred to and are similar to
our standard of first name and last name
for our young Pharaoh these were nebka
parar and Tariq Arman these last two
names were always marked distinctly in
Egyptian inscriptions to show that they
referred to a royal name by encasing
them in an oval with a line at one end
called cartouche so if we put all that
together and translate it Tut's full
name would have been the strong ball
pleasing of birth one of perfect laws he
pacifies the two lands elevated of
appearances who satisfied the gods lord
of the forms of rah the living image of
a moon that's quite a mouthful so it's
not exactly surprising that most people
just call him to tank Harmon however
there are some ancient inscriptions with
variants on his name which are even
longer you would think that this is the
end of it but there is actually one more
point to make about his name when he was
born circa 1341 BC his personal name was
actually Tooting hearten meaning the
living image of Artin this was because
of his father Akina tan or Amenhotep the
fourth who was one of the most
controversial Pharaoh's in history and
someone you will likely see on this
channel at some point in the future the
religion of ancient Egypt is still
pretty well known to this day as we've
all heard of gods like Horace and Anubis
and to Cyrus and most importantly of all
the Sun God Arman rah well a Connaughton
decided to do away with all of that and
a focus worship on a single deity Artin
the Sun disc the Pharaoh even had a
city built dedicated to this God which
was intended to function as the new
capital of his empire he called it a
Kurtz hearten modern-day amana suffice
to say people did not take too kindly to
this religious revolution after
Akhenaten dydz they quickly relocated
the capital back to Thebes and went back
to their old religion they even
submitted a cannot and you damnatio
memoriae the practice where they tried
to completely wipe him from history by
erasing his name from all inscriptions
and well we're talking about him now so
clearly they didn't do a great job of it
but this is why Tutankhamun originally
had the name Tutankhaten and why he
changed it afterwards
as far as Tut's mother goes she's a bit
more of a mystery since surviving
inscriptions do not make her identity
clearer some Egyptologists argue that
his mother was Nefertiti herself the
famous Egyptian queen who was a cannot
ins main wife or great royal wife as she
was called others are convinced that his
mother was an unnamed mummy discovered
over a century ago referred to simply as
the younger lady modern DNA tests
support this assertion but some experts
are still not convinced some of them
argue that the tests are inconclusive
due to decayed samples while others a
pine that the mummy is in fact Nefertiti
as as her remains have never been found
tatang commands ascension to the throne
is somewhat murky because as we said
later Pharaohs tried to make it look
like part of their history never
happened to the best of our knowledge
Akhenaten reigns for seventeen years and
he was followed by two short rains
before Tutankhamun took the throne those
two reins belonged to spank a car a
Pharaoh about whom we know almost
nothing and Nephi for newellton la fille
ma Pharaoh who was most likely Nefertiti
or one of Akhenaten's daughters one or
both of them may have reigned as Co
regions with a kin darton prior to his
death around 1334 BC Tutankhamun assumed
power he was still just a young boy only
eight or nine years old so his decisions
were heavily influenced by his advisers
particularly there was one advisor named
I who served at the Kings Court since
the time of Akhenaten it is believed he
was the main power hiding in the shadows
who actually made the decisions
during totes rain and indeed after the
young king died are you actually became
the new Pharaoh he only lasted a few
years before he was succeeded by another
of Tut's officials horemheb who ended up
serving as the last Pharaoh of the
eighteenth dynasty Tutankhamen's tenure
reign as the ruler of Egypt who is
unremarkable the country was still in
chaos due to his father's religious
revolution and the young pharaoh
undoubtedly guided by his advisors
renounced his father's ideas and began
restoring things to how they were before
the Amana period this mostly involved
rebuilding temples monuments and Stalley
which were either destroyed or defaced
during the time of Akhenaten he also
abandons the city of Aachen Tartan and
moved the capital back to Thebes and
changed his name from to Connaughton to
tutenkhamun's who showed the Pharaohs
devotion to the once mighty God took
married his half-sister anchored
cinnamon and together they had two
daughters who both died in infancy
some scholars believed that the Queen
went on to marry I after Tutankhamun's
death but there isn't conclusive
evidence to support this perhaps the
most noteworthy events that happened
during the time came courtesy nots of
King tarts but his wife after the young
Pharaoh's death anchor cinnamon may have
written a letter to the king of the
Hittites suppiluliuma the first asking
for of his sons in marriage
the Hittites had long been a thorn in
egypt's side and taking advantage of the
chaos during the reign of a kin Darton
they grew to be just as powerful it
would have been the first time that son
of the foreign King would have ruled
over Egypt and obviously simpler Llumar
was over the moon with the idea he sent
his son Prince's ananza to marry her but
he died somewhere on the route the exact
circumstances of his death and not known
although many speculates that he was
assassinated on the orders of I or her n
had bought perhaps both as for
Tutankhamun and like we said before his
reign was nothing to write home about
the boy king would surely have been
relegated to a footnote in the history
books were it not for the events that
occurred thousands of years after his
death in 1325 BC but just before we do
make that jump forward in time let me
thank today's sponsor a curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and non fake
titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers including exclusive originals
if you're enjoying this one then why not
try out curiosity stream for free and
check out their content on ancient Egypt
not a big surprise that they've got
loads of that specific recommendation
from me the story of King Tut's tomb
which is well worth a watch easy to find
on that curiosity streams available on
many platforms as web app Roku Android
Xbox one the list really does go on it's
also available worldwide so wherever you
are you can get it get unlimited access
starting at just two dollars 99
and for you guys the first 30 days are
completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm forward slash
buyer graphics and use the promo code
biographic s' during the signup process
there's also a link below it's a great
way to support this show and let's get
back to the video so now we leave
ancient Egypt's and travel over three
thousand years into the future where
people had easier to pronounce names we
are in the same region which is now
known as the Valley of the Kings because
it had been used as a burial site for
pharaohs and other important ancient
officials for almost five hundred years
it had been excavated by archaeologists
since the early 1800s and at the start
of the 20th century there was this
general belief that people thought
everything there had already been found
the man in charge of excavations
american explorer Theodore Davis
famously entered a paper published in
1912 with the words I fear that the
Valley of the Kings is now exhausted
Davis died in 1915 and the rights to
excavate the valley were bought by an
English aristocrat named George
Herbert's the 5th Earl of Carnarvon he
had in his employ an archaeologist named
Howard Carter who had been digging for
him since 1907 but without any
tremendous success
Carter relocated to the Valley of the
Kings and resumed his work for Lord
conovan but again many years went by
without any significant discoveries in
1922 connivance started to feel like
davis may have been right all along and
there truly wasn't anything left in the
Valley of the Kings
he told Carter that he would only fund
one more season of digging before he
abandons the
Valley for good cartas time was running
out but in November that year he made
the discovery of the century according
to his own journal the serendipitous
moments occurred by accident on November
the 4th when his waterboy stumbled over
a stone upon closer inspection that
stone turned out to be the top of a set
of stairs buried in the sand
understandably excited Carter excavated
the spot and found that the stairs led
to a burial site of great significance
based on the Royal seals
he wrote to Lord Kanha Verne and waited
the arrival of his benefactor before
going in sight on November the 26th
Carter carnaval and his daughter Evelyn
Herbert became the first people to enter
the tomb of Tutankhamun in over 3,000
years almost immediately the
archaeologists realized the magnitude of
the find as he saw everywhere the glint
of gold statues cups beds and even a
throne filled antechamber which led to
another room with a sealed doorway at
this point it wasn't clear yet what
Carter had found was this simply a
treasure cache or was there an actual
burial chamber waiting for them behind
that doorway
they had to wait a bit to get their
answer it wasn't until February 1923
that Carter was finally able to enter
the closed chamber and glimpse for the
first time the sarcophagus of King Tut
afterwards Carter and his team spent the
next decade cataloguing preserving and
removing over 5,000 objects that were
sitting in that tomb
[Music]
[Applause]
the tomb of Tutankhamen which was
designated kV 62 consisted of four rooms
a corridor and a staircase contrary to
what is commonly believed the burial
site was not completely pristine it had
been targeted by thieves in the past
it's just that the looting happened soon
after Tut's burial and Egyptian
officials had had time to fix the
problem some of the doors showed signs
of repairs and being sealed more than
once it appears that the tomb was robbed
twice the first time the thief didn't
get away with much but they did steal
things like oils and cosmetics which
were highly prized in ancient Egyptian
society such items would not have lasted
long so obviously the theft occurred
soon after the objects were placed
inside the tomb the second occasion was
more complex and organized and involved
digging a tunnel inside the burial
chamber and accessing the treasury the
room was filled with jewelry and athief
stole a lot of it the scene suggested
that they had been caught in the act
since had to make a hasty getaway which
was why they left so much stuff behind
even with these acts of vandalism kV 62
was still the most complete Pharaoh's
tomb ever discovered then of course
there was the burial chamber the main
event as it were which contains the
mummy of the boy King this was the only
room which had decorations on the walls
which depicted the Pharaoh and multiple
deities taking part in various
ceremonies the bulk of the room was
taken up by four gilded shrines made out
of wood the shrines were each smaller
than the last and were placed inside
each other like Russian nesting dolls
and inside the smallest shrine there was
the sarcophagus inside the sarcophagus
there was a similar situation as the
mummy was placed inside of three coffins
the two outer were made of gilded wood
like the shrines but it was the
innermost coffin which immediately
attracted attention as it was made of
over 240 pounds of pure gold inside the
coffin was a Pharaoh's mummy of course
which was wearing a gold funerary mask
adorned with precious jewels which has
probably become the most famous artifact
from ancient Egypt as Egyptologists
studied this treasure trove of artifacts
they couldn't help but notice that this
tomb may have been never intended for
Tutankhamun at all some items showed
signs that they previously contained
different names which had been raised
and Tutankhamun's name written on top of
them this alone could have been
explained by officials wanting to remove
the Pharaohs original name to turn
hearten
there were plenty of other curious
features which suggested that the tomb
was originally built for an old man
the most common theory is that it was
intended for Smeg cajas the mysterious
Pharaoh that ruled for a little bit
before King taught for decades scholars
have argued over the possibility of the
being more chambers hidden inside kV 62
one of them could even contain the
elusive resting place of Nefertiti but
this argument seemed destined to remain
unsettled since for obvious reasons
nobody was allowed to start smashing up
the burial chamber in search of
undiscovered rooms however modern
technology provided us with an
uninteresting to the problem
ground-penetrating radar scans this
technique was not without controversy
the first scans took place in 2015 and
detected the presence of open spaces
which backed up the idea that there was
more to find in Tut's tomb however a
subsequent test failed to replicate
these results the third and final scan
was performed in 2018 by three different
companies which negated the initial
findings and detected nothing but solid
rock the Egyptian Ministry of
Antiquities has accepted these results
and there are no four other plans to
search for chambers as far as the items
inside the tumor concerns we are
obviously not going to talk about all of
them since there are over 5000 of them
we already mentioned the most important
ones but there are a few more curious
objects that merit inclusion for example
the tomb contained a pair of trumpets
one silver and the other one either
bronze or copper which may be the oldest
functional trumpets in the world
these ancient instruments were actually
played once in 1939 on an international
BBC broadcast which was heard by
approximately a hundred and fifty
million people there is one final item
to mention which is out of this world
literally it's a dagger whose blade was
made out of iron meteorite his exact
origins are unclear as the quality metal
work is uncharacteristic of Egypt's in
touch time so either ancient Egyptians
were far more skilled iron craftsmen
than we previously thought or the dagger
was a gift from another place it's
extraterrestrial credentials were
confirmed with the help of a
spectrometer which detected high levels
of nickel and cobalt indicative of iron
from a meteorite
[Music]
studying all the artifacts inside the
tomb was all well and good but what
about the mummy it won't surprise you to
learn that the body of Tutankhamun has
been examined and discussed extensively
it probably also won't surprise you to
discover that the young inbred King
wasn't exactly the peak of physical
health in fact he was frail disabled
suffered from one or more genetic
abnormalities and probably needed a cane
to walk around before we get into any
specifics we should mention that
Tutankhamen's health is the subject of
multiple studies and many of them
contradict or disagree with each other
so there isn't universal acceptance
regarding the Pharaohs health problems
and they also include a fair bit of
speculation let's start with the minor
stuff Todd had several features which
were believed to be genetic traits of
his bloodline they included a small
cleft palate and overbite and larger
than normal Center in sizes he also had
an unusually elongated skull shape which
again was thought to be an abnormality
that ran in his family Todd had trouble
walking and although it was initially
believed this was due to a stress
fracture caused by an accident recent
research indicates that he was actually
born with a severe clubfoot his
condition may have gotten even worse as
the years went by as he may have also
suffered from a degenerative bone
condition called Kohler disease his
spine was curved and showed fusion in
the upper vertebrae which some believed
could have been a sign of Marfan
syndrome although this idea was later
dismissed by the most recent tests the
malformation on his leg would have been
so extreme that the Pharaoh would not
have been able to walk without a cane as
proof of this scholars point to the fact
that over 100 walking canes were buried
with the young king in his tomb there is
a reason why not everyone is on board
with this idea though and that's because
it cancels out one of the main theories
regarding Tutankhamun's death some
Egyptologists are of the firm opinion
that the boy king died from injuries
suffered in a chariot crash however if
his foot was as bad as this new study
indicates then it would have been
impossible for him to ride in a chariot
this brings us neatly to our next point
and that's what killed him
there is no mention of his cause of
death in ancient records and examining
the remains didn't reveal an obvious
answer for decades it was believed that
Tut's death came as the result of foul
x-ray scans performed in the 1960s
showed that the young pharaoh had bone
fragments inside his skull indicative of
a blow to the hat however newer tests
revealed that the bits of bone ended up
there in modern times when the mummy was
removed from its coffin there were no
other signs to suggest a fatal head blow
then there is the aforementioned chariot
crash theory which asserts that
Tutankhamun died either due to direct
injuries sustained in a chariot crash or
from an infection that came as a result
of it adherents of this idea point to
damage done to the young Kings ribs and
chest which could be indicative of
crushing injuries plus images in his
tomb that depict the Pharaoh riding a
chariot in battle again opponents of
this theory believed these injuries were
caused recently while handling the money
the most up-to-date research actually
suggests that he died from malaria tests
performed a decade ago found traces of
the infection in four mummies including
Tutankhamun this compounded with all the
other health problems that lowered his
immune system could be the culprits that
cuts the pharaoh's reign short there is
no universally accepted solution but
this is at the moment the most prevalent
theory the obsession with death
surrounding Tutankhamun hasn't really
been restricted to his own demise after
all many people died after the tomb was
opened because they dared to disturb the
sleep of the Pharaoh didn't they I mean
we've all heard about the notorious
curse of the Pharaohs it has been
mentioned since the 19th century but it
was the discovery of Tut's tomb that
made it infinitely more popular and
helped it to reach the public
consciousness however there is no actual
curse inscribed anywhere inside kV 62
there was a fabrication of the
newspapers there is one suspicious death
surrounding the discovery of the tomb
one single death that set off the mania
of the Mummy's curse lured conovan the
man who funded Carter's digging died a
few months after entering the tomb he
succumbed to blood poisoning and the
newspapers immediately started doubting
the curse of the Pharaohs
since then anything bad or remotely
suspicious that happened to one of the
dozens of people involved with the mummy
has been ascribed to the curse however
the British Medical Journal actually did
a scientific study and found that the
life expectancy rate for those people
wasn't higher
lower than average it was just that the
abnormal cases received much more media
attention
the study also debunked another notion
which said that there was a more direct
way in which the tomb caused the demise
of conovan and others and that's ancient
mold spores which they inhales and it
caused damage do their respiratory
systems this didn't happen because if it
did that have all died really quickly
rather than after months or years so you
can rest assured that if you disturb a
thorough slumbers you won't be cursed
well let's just say probably so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below do check out our fantastic
sponsor curiosity stream linking to them
below and thank you for watching
[Music]